[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARIO GALARRETA: OK.
Hi, everybody.
And welcome.
Thank you for joining
us in the room
or over the Livestream for
this new edition of Talks
at Google sponsored by gPause.
My name is Mario
Galarreta, I work
in the Well-Being and
Learning Team that's
part of People Development.
And we manage programs like
Search Inside Yourself, gPause,
Sustaining, 10x, [INAUDIBLE],,
Fundamentals of Mindfulness,
[? gCalm. ?]
And today, it's
my great pleasure
as a neuroscientist
to welcome to Google,
introduce Dr. Amishi Jha.
She is Associate Professor in
the Department of Psychology
at the University of Miami.
She's also the Director of
Contemplative Neuroscience
for the Mindfulness Research
and Practice Initiative
also at the University of Miami.
And she's a world-class
scientist studying
the neural basis of attention.
And studying the
effect, the impact
of mindfulness and
mindfulness trainings
in different aspects of
cognition, emotion, and also
resilience.
Actually, she's the
lead author in one
of the very early papers,
2007, 10 years ago,
studying the impact of
mindfulness training
on attention.
Over the years, she
has focused her work
in the impact of mindfulness
and mindfulness trainings
in different aspects, including
education, sports, military,
the business.
Right now, her lab is currently
doing a number of studies
from working with active
military soldiers,
with accountants,
with football players,
with firefighters,
groups of people exposed
to high demands,
high-performance, high-stress
work environments.
So I think her work is very
relevant to our programs
and to us at Google.
And please, help me welcome
warmly to Google, Dr. Amishi
Jha.
AMISHI JHA: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, Mario.
All right.
Hello, everyone.
It's my great
pleasure to be here.
And as you can see from
Mario's gracious introduction
and the title of
my talk, I'd like
to share with you today
work we've been doing
and that the broader field
of contemplative neuroscience
has been doing
around mindfulness.
But I think that
before I jump right in,
it might be helpful to
understand the perspective I
take in the work that
I do, to kind of frame
where I'm coming from in the
kind of research questions I
ask and the orientation I take.
So as Mario mentioned,
my expertise
is in the topic of the human
brain's attention system.
And the bulk of my research
over many years of my lab
has been on understanding the
brain mechanisms of attention.
So we use a variety of cognitive
neuroscience techniques
to study attention.
Things like functional
MRI, brain wave recordings,
or Event-Related
Potentials, ERPs,
as well as behavioral tasks that
are sort of like simple video
games that allow us to tax
attention in specific ways
that we can measure the impact.
And through doing this,
we've learned a lot about how
attention works in the brain.
And we basically have
learned that where
we direct our attention
biases the processing
of the rest of the brain.
And in some ways, you can
think about this as attention
being the brain's boss.
Wherever attention goes, the
rest of the brain will follow.
Which means it has a powerful
responsibility with regard
to where we put our attention.
And through the course
of understanding
the basics of
attention, we've also
come to understand that
there are some things that
are essentially like
kryptonite for our brain's
system of attention.
And those are listed here.
We know that with high
stress, poor mood, and threat,
our attention system will
become compromised and degraded.
It won't function the
way we want it to,
which is particularly
problematic because that's
probably-- those are the kinds
of circumstances in which we
want to be absolutely sure that
our attention is working well
because we'll lean on it.
And after understanding
this for several years,
it became sort of a
compelling question for me
to figure out what
we could do about it.
So if we know there
are circumstances
in which attention
is compromised,
how might we train the
brain's attention system
to be protected against this?
Because it's unlikely for
the kinds of professions
and personnel that we
involve in our research,
it's unlikely that we can
avoid them ever having--
in fact, as human
beings, it's unlikely
that we can avoid
having experiences
in our lives of stress,
poor mood, and threat.
I wish we could, but sorry.
So that's where
mindfulness training
comes into my lab's work.
And what I'll share with you
is the studies that we've
been up to, but also the state
of the field of this research.
And of course, because
science is a team sport,
but I'm the only one
up here speaking,
I wanted to give a shout-out
to my wonderful team
of collaborators
and lab members.
And one of them is here
today, Scott Rogers,
who has been a real key
collaborator for me,
because he's the one that
actually helps design and run
many of the training protocols.
So I'm just very
grateful for this group
of people that allow me
to actually have something
to tell you.
All right.
So let's jump right in.
See this image here.
100 years ago, if you told
people that you might willingly
get on a bike that's had
its back wheel removed,
and pedal as hard and
fast as you possibly
can to get absolutely
nowhere, I mean,
you'd think that there were--
it was preposterous, right?
But that's exactly what so many
of us do on a regular basis.
So my question is really,
what's going on here?
And I think that the answer to
the question on the next slide
gives us some insight into this.
So answer this question,
does physical exercise
improve physical health?
For people in the
room, raise your hand
if you think the answer is yes.
OK.
Let the record show that's every
single person in this room,
right?
And I'm getting some strange
looks like, why are you asking
such a ridiculous question?
And what I want
to suggest to you
is the reason we get
on exercise bikes
or we go for jogs is because we
have a cultural understanding
that this is true, that we need
to exercise our bodies to be
physically healthy.
It's such a common
understanding that we
think it's a ridiculous
question to ask.
But what I want to suggest to
you-- and actually, argue--
is that this understanding
didn't come out of thin air.
It actually came through a
dedicated set of research
questions and science
that pursued understanding
the relationship with
regard to physical health
and physical exercise.
And one of the key, really,
pioneers in this area
was actually an Air Force
captain, who wrote-- literally,
wrote the book
called "Aerobics."
He was one of the
first people who put,
maybe 27,000 or so
military service members
through lots of different tests
to come up with what we now
consider everyday knowledge.
This notion of
10,000 steps a day,
or the fact that our
cardiovascular health depends
on our ability to
engage in certain kinds
of aerobic exercise
comes from his work.
And of course, many, many other
research studies followed.
And the way in which
this field of research
has parsed the question
of physical health
and physical exercise
is as follows, right?
We know that we can
look at the physiology.
We can actually
conduct research that
has people exercising and look
at their oxygen consumption,
or whatever it is.
Carbon dioxide levels
in the blood, et cetera.
And that gives us an
indication of their health.
So while they're actually
performing the act of exercise,
we can look at them.
We can look at
people that choose
as a lifestyle to engage in
physical activity-- elite
athletes.
And we can see what their
physiology looks like at rest,
to see if it differs from
those that don't actually
exercise on a regular basis.
And that there are differences
in the direction of health.
We can look at structural
changes or protein expression.
There are so many
different ways we
can establish the
link between engaging
in particular
activities and health.
And, finally performance.
We can look at how people
do when they actually
engage in activity in
terms of how well they
perform a challenge task, for
example, of running a marathon.
So this type of research
has actually resulted in--
and this is an
underestimation, probably,
around 300,000 articles
since 1980 that
have been done on this topic.
And that volume of
research is what I would
say is why we have the answer.
So plainly, yes.
That of course,
physical activity
is tied to physical health.
OK.
So I want to make that point.
It seems trivial, but it
didn't come out of nowhere.
And that now because
of this research,
we are at a point
in our culture--
and actually, around the
world, that our public health
officials can give us very
precise evidence-based guidance
on what to do.
It's not just that
it's good for us,
but here's what you
should do to optimize.
All right.
So I think I've made that point.
And I want to switch gears to
a different kind of a question.
Does mental exercise improve
psychological well-being?
How many people would say yes?
Raise your hand.
All right, fine.
It's unanimous in the room.
But I always like to
think-- you didn't wander
in here accidentally, right?
So I think I was talking
to a warmer crowd anyway.
But if I actually
probed you right now
and said exactly
what you should do,
I bet the diversity of
opinion would be quite high.
And part of the reason
is because we're not
at the same level as we are
with regard to an evidence
base regarding what
you should do in order
to stay psychologically fit.
And what mental
exercises you should do.
And that's sort of
the project of what
we're talking about with regard
to the science of mindfulness.
It's really to
systematically and rigorously
be able to ask this question to
see what role it has to play.
Now, it's not only
scientists that
are interested in understanding
the answer to this question.
Of course, the National
Institutes of Health
is very interested in
understanding the answer
to this question.
And what they've
done now is surveyed
a broad group of US society.
And what they found is
that many people engage--
willingly, on their own, engage
in certain mind-body practices
to benefit their
psychological well-being.
And meditation, of which this
term mindfulness meditation
is a subset, is practiced by
about 8% of the US population
according to NIH's numbers.
Right
So you might ask, well, what
is driving people to do this?
What is their
number 1 explanation
for what motivates them
to practice meditation?
Well, it's this.
And I mean, I don't really
like showing this slide.
I think it's kind of stressful.
But it does really
suggest to us that there's
a motivating factor
that most of us--
the bottom-line denominator
of what all of us
experience in our lives that
make us wanting to do something
to help ourselves.
And when I give this
type of presentation
and I say stress, especially
to military audiences,
I usually get
immediate push-back,
like what are you talking about?
Stress allows me to
rise to the challenge.
I'm at my peak because
there's something driving me.
There's a deadline.
There's a challenge before me.
I have to be at my excellence,
at my best to achieve it.
And my answer to
that is absolutely.
So I want to describe
to you a very well, kind
of explored function
that describes
what a lot of these service
members are saying to me,
which is the Yerkes-Dodson law.
It may be familiar
to some of you.
And what it's
saying, essentially,
is that there is a lawful
relationship between the amount
of stress or challenge
we experience,
the amount of demand
which is shown on the
x-axis, and our performance
on the y-axis.
What it suggests is that,
sure, when our stress is low,
when we have nothing
driving us, our performance
isn't that great--
back down at the
bottom near the origin.
But as our stress
increases, we do actually
rise to the challenge.
Our performance does
increase until we
reach that sweet spot, what
we might call "optimum stress,
optimal stress."
And everything on sort of
this side of that sweet spot,
we'd call eustress,
or good stress.
But when we pass
that tipping point,
that right amount of stress
to optimize performance,
we're no longer going to
benefit from increasing stress.
At that point, the
curve starts going down.
And what we learn is that
performance actually declines.
And we would no longer call
that beneficial stress.
We'd call it distress.
And this is what unfortunately
happens to many of us,
even if something
started out as eustress
because it was the right amount
of challenge and motivation,
if you have to experience
that amount of stress
for a protracted period of
time, it doesn't let up,
the chronic effects of that
are that they do result
in psychological distress.
So that's what I'm
talking about right now.
I'm talking about
this notion that there
are levels of demand,
situational challenges,
psychological challenges,
even physical challenges, that
put us at not allowing
optimal functioning.
And of course, then
an obvious question
might be, what can
we do about it?
And as I mentioned,
there are populations
of people for whom
they don't have
much of a choice in
the level of demand
that they may experience.
So I like to share this
photo montage collage.
Actually, it was a
part of a project that
was done to just capture
the faces of soldiers
as they're in
pre-deployment training,
during deployment, and even
upon return from deployment.
And if you just let your
eyes kind of rest on that,
you'll see what I'm
talking about here.
Right And I love
this St. Jerome quote
to sort of capture what
we see, "The face is
the mirror of the mind.
The eyes without
speaking confess
the secrets of the heart."
And we see it.
We see the costs of protracted
periods of high demand
in everything about us.
So what has been a big
motivating factor for me
in the research
that I've taken on
is to see if there's
something we can do about it.
Is there some way in
which we could actually
explore this
systematically, rigorously,
applying the tools of
contemplative practice
and mindfulness
training to be of help?
So let me just describe to
you kind of the paradigm
that I'm thinking about.
If the broad question
is, how can we
best protect individuals over
high stress periods of time?
And that is to think about
some constrained time point.
We'll call it time
1 because that's
the beginning of when
we're going to start
evaluating the effects.
And we've got some multi-week
or multi-month period of time
that we call the high-demand
or high-stress interval.
And at the end of that,
we're going to call it--
or not even the end.
At some period of time, we're
going to call that time 2.
And time 1 and time 2 are
really just the evaluation time
points, where we're
going to probe something
about the participants
or the people
experiencing the stress to
see what the effects are
of high-demand intervals.
So what we know is, if we don't
have a high-demand interval,
if we're in sort of
normative civilian life.
You don't have a
big project due.
You have no special events
coming up in your life.
There might be
little fluctuations
around our level of
well-being, which this cartoon
graph is sort of describing.
But it's pretty
much staying stable.
That's what this
dotted line is saying,
that we have some normative
amount of psychological health.
And the prediction is--
and if we just talked about
this sort of more ordinarily,
we'd say yeah, of
course, I feel worse
at the end of a
high-demand interval
than I did at the
beginning of it.
But the prediction
is that we can
track that well-being
will be worse
at the end of a high-demand
period than before.
And if this is a
knowable trajectory
of what will happen to
people's state of mind
as they enter high stress,
and we can know what
those high-stress
periods of time are,
let's do something about it.
So I want to switch gears
now, because as I mentioned,
I'm an attention researcher.
I'm not actually a clinician.
Of course, I'm interested
in well-being also,
my own and those of others.
But what I study is attention.
So I wanted to I wanted to talk
a little bit about attention,
and how it relates to what I'm
describing as the consequences
of high stress.
What I'm showing you
here is basically
two metaphors for two important
brain systems that are-- we
could call them close
cousins of each other.
The attention system, I use
the metaphor of a flashlight.
So attention allows you to
direct your mental resources
at will to a particular
part of space
or the internal
landscape, for example.
And wherever that
attention is directed
will benefit from
preferential processing.
If you're in a darkened room
and you direct a flashlight,
you're going to see what's going
on in that location better.
So as a psychological system,
attention does the same thing.
Working memory, is its,
sort of like I said,
close cousin system in the sense
that whatever is selected then
in working memory is maintained
and manipulated for use.
So I like to give the example,
I use the white board here as--
you can think of it as
the mental scratch space.
Whatever we need to have ready
access to, we put up there.
But it's a mental scratch space.
It's a white board
with disappearing ink.
It doesn't stay
on there forever.
So think of the last
time, for example,
you were having a
conversation with somebody.
And they were talking
and you had an idea.
And you wanted to express it.
But you're not going to be rude.
You're going to hold
that idea in your mind
till there's a good break in
what they're saying to speak.
That's an example of just having
taxed your working memory.
You had to hold that in mind.
Not forever, but
just long enough
to be able to deliver it.
Or, think about-- it's
happening to me more and more
than I'd care to admit.
But walking into a
room on a mission
to get something from
that room, getting there,
and having no idea what you
were looking for, right?
That's a failure
of working memory.
That that scratch
space didn't serve you
because you're looking
at that white board
and there's nothing there.
You have no idea.
The point is both
of these systems
are critical for literally
everything we do.
And I'm listing some of
the important functions
of attention and working memory.
This ability to select
and maintain information.
From planning, communicating,
learning, even our ability
to regulate our own
emotions requires intact
working memory and attention.
And of course, bigger things,
like the decisions we make.
And finally, the actions
that we produce in the world.
All of these require our
intact systems functioning.
So now, let's talk
about what we think
would happen to attention over
high-demand periods of time.
Same prediction.
Whereas, normal life
might, where there's not
a lot of major stressors
happening-- the demand
levels are pretty up and
down, but pretty normal.
Normative levels of attention.
But under high
stress, we predict
a systematic linear
decline in the availability
and functioning of attention.
Now as I said, for many of
the people that we work with,
this is very important.
And I would say, probably
everybody in this room as well.
Because if we are experiencing
a period of high demand,
typically that
means that we have
to be functioning
at a high level.
And we may actually be
experiencing high demand
because we are
required to function
at a high level for a
long period of time.
And what this is
suggesting to us
is that the very thing you need
to function well and perform
well may actually
be getting depleted
as a result of the high demand
that you're experiencing.
So at the end of
that period of time,
you may have to do something
big, like give a presentation,
or have a new product release,
or go to war in the case
of some of our participants.
It's at that moment
that you may have less
of what you need to do well.
OK.
And you know, of
course, as I mentioned,
we work with groups like
soldiers, or firefighters,
or high-stress,
high-demand groups.
And when we think about
service members in particular,
it may seem like kind
of not relatable.
But just remember
that for all of us,
there is a sense of what a
mental war zone feels like.
Our consequences may not be life
or death in a literal sense.
But many times, the
stresses we face
feel like they have life
or death consequences.
And in some sense, our
physiology and our brain
don't care what the reality is.
We get hijacked in the same way
and the costs, unfortunately,
are the same.
So I hope that helps
relate a lot of this work
to our kind of
everyday experience,
for those of us that aren't
preparing for a war zone.
All right.
So what this brings
up is this notion
of how we would
protect our attention.
And I use this phrase
"cognitive resilience."
I mean, resilience
is a broad term
that has to do with bouncing
back from challenge.
Cognitive resilience
I'm going to unpack.
And apologies in advance for
the very academic-sounding
description.
"The ability to
maintain or regain
cognitive capacities at risk
for degradation, depletion,
or failure in the face
of situational challenges
experienced over
protracted time periods."
So basically, it's
sort of this desire
to hold steady with
our functioning,
even though the
challenges are increasing.
And if we can do this,
we have the best chances
of performing well under those
circumstances that bring it
about as high challenge.
All right.
So the question
really is, can we
provide some kind
of mental training
in which we can keep
this line steady,
even though the people
that we're working with
are experiencing high demand?
And I want to now connect
the dots between everything
I've said.
I'm an attention researcher.
I'm talking about stress
and the costs of stress.
And I'm interested
in mindfulness.
So this image should help
you hopefully understand
where I'm coming from.
Everybody know what this is?
It's a music player.
And essentially, my
proposal is that the mind is
very much like a music player.
It is an exquisite mental
time-traveling machine.
We can very easily
rewind our mind
to the past to reflect on
events that have happened.
And we can very easily
fast forward the mind
to plan for the future.
And that ability to go in
reverse or fast forward
is essentially the
ability to control when
in time our attention lives.
So even if we're obviously
in the present moment,
if our mind is on
the past, we're
actually missing what's
happening in the present moment
because we have been hijacked
to the past or the future.
And this relates to stress,
because most of the time
when we're stuck in this
mental time-travel mode,
it's not just a
pleasant reflection
of events that have gone
by or a wonderful visioning
of positive outcomes
for the future.
It's usually not that
way for most of us.
It's actually stress.
And what we know is
that a stressed mind
is more prone to this type
of mental time travel.
And most studies now
say that the amount
of time we spend not
in the present moment,
but actually in mind
wandering is about 50--
about 30% to 50% of
our waking moments.
30% to 50% of our
waking moments we're not
actually in the present moment.
And when we aren't in
the present moment,
it's tied to things like
ruminating, reliving,
or regretting
experiences in the past.
Anybody ever experience that?
Right.
Or when we're in
fast forward, we
are actually not just
productively planning.
But sometimes, worst-case
scenario planning,
catastrophizing, or
worrying about events
that not only haven't
happened yet, but may never,
ever happen.
So I hope this helps understand
why as an attention researcher,
I care about mind wandering.
And why I powerfully
understand that stress
can promote mind wandering and
this hijacking of attention.
So what I'd like
to suggest to you,
at least based on our research,
is that at least theoretically,
we could think
about the antidote
to a stressed wandering
mind as a mindful one.
And this helps highlight
the way that I think
about what mindfulness is.
So mindfulness, I would say,
is keeping that button right
on play.
It is about having this kind
of mental mode, this mindset
in which we are attending to
our present moment experience.
We're in the here and the now.
And to read this definition--
again, kind of more formal,
"A mental mode
characterized by attention
to present moment experience
without conceptual elaboration
or emotional reactivity."
Or to put it more
plainly, it's about being
in the here and the now
without a story about it.
And this ability to be
in the here and the now
may sound like a great idea.
It's like, yeah, I
want to be present.
It doesn't always
come easily for us,
which is why training
programs that really allow
us to exercise the
muscle of attention,
to put it in this perspective
is important for us
to really be able to do this.
Because unfortunately,
as I said a moment ago,
when we're stressed, we're
less likely to be in the now.
We're more likely to be
ruminating about the past
or worrying about the future.
So it's almost like we have
to have this strengthened
before we go into a
high-demand scenario,
so we're protected against
what the mind will, left
to its own devices, do.
OK.
So I'm going to unpack
a little bit about what
I mean by mindfulness, by giving
you kind of an under the hood.
And I'm sure this is
familiar to many of you
who practice
mindfulness, but this
is a foundational
mindfulness exercise.
And I think of it as
really circuit training
for the brain's
attention system.
So let me break down the kind
of key components of what
we do in a mindfulness
of breathing exercise.
And this is one intended to
cultivate focused attention.
So what we'd ask our
participants to do
is for some dedicated period
of time, let's say 10 minutes,
you're going to sit in a
comfortable, upright, alert
posture, focus all
of your attention
to the sensations of breathing.
So you're going
to constrain where
that flashlight is focused now.
And you're going to be
even more constrained.
You're going to select a
very specific sensation tied
to the breath,
whatever's most prominent
for that period of time.
It could be coolness of
air moving in and out
of your nostrils, or your
abdomen moving in and out.
Whatever it is, you're
going to select it.
And then, that's
essentially the target
for your attention for the
period of formal practice.
Then, the instruction
is essentially, OK.
You've got the focus,
now maintain it there.
And as any of you that have
tried it certainly know,
we don't always do what
we're told, our mind is told,
even if we are
telling ourselves.
And attention
doesn't stay stably
on this breath-focused
sensation, it will wander.
So in anticipation of that, the
third part of the instruction
is when you notice your mind
has wandered-- not if you've
noticed your mind has wandered,
when because it will wander.
The first key is notice.
So keep this kind of
watchful perspective
to see, where is the
contents of consciousness?
Is it on the breath or
is it somewhere else?
When you notice your
mind has wandered,
gently return it back.
Right So nothing
big to do about it,
just be aware of
where attention is.
And when it's not where you'd
like it to be, redirect it.
So the reason I've highlighted
these words "select,"
"maintain," "notice"
and "mind wander,"
is because those
are the key features
from a cognitive training
perspective that we hypothesize
are being trained by
repeated engagement.
And what we want to do in the
kind of program of research
that I've been involved in is
to see if our hunch is correct.
If we're training these
particular systems,
we might expect that the
strength of our ability
to select, maintain, and
control our mind wandering
may be improved.
So that's what
we're looking for.
All right.
And I want to just take a
moment to say what mindfulness
practice isn't.
And again, for those of
you who practice this,
it will sound familiar.
But I do think it's important.
And as I mentioned,
a lot of times
I'm briefing audiences
who not only don't
know about mindfulness, but
don't care and are highly
skeptical of the fact that
this Indian woman has decided
to give them a talk on a topic.
So it's sort of like
protecting myself to say, look,
I'm a neuroscientist,
and what I'm
trying to tell you is
very specific with regard
to the way I'm talking
about mindfulness.
And it's not a way to
shut down all thoughts.
That's not the project
of mindfulness.
There is no mention of trying
to do anything with thoughts
other than when the focus is
not on the intended object
to redirect it back.
It's actually not
about deep breathing.
You know, yoga is
now very popular.
And a lot of people
conflate what
we're trying to do with a
yogic breathing exercise, which
is very powerful, but that's not
what we're talking about here.
We're not talking
about manipulating
present-moment experience.
We're talking about observing
what is happening right now.
It's actually not a
relaxation technique,
though many times people
engaging in these practices
can feel much more kind
of calm and relaxed.
Because remember, the
main instruction is alert.
Sort of tranquil and alert
may be the good pairing.
The other thing is that it's
not esoteric or mystical
in any way.
It's not a special
state of being.
And that these practices really
come from the world's wisdom
traditions.
Almost every major religious
or spiritual tradition
around the world has some
aspect of contemplative practice
in it.
And what we're doing
from the science side
is trying to draw
upon that world wisdom
to see if there's
mental training that
could be helpful, and
strengthen the brain,
and make it more fit.
Also-- I wanted to
mention this because I
think this is important--
you don't need to do it
for hours on end, days
on end, years on end
for it to be beneficial.
And some of the work
that we're doing now
in collaboration with my
colleague Scott Rogers is
we're trying to see,
what's the lower limit?
What is sort of the least
amount of time in our efficient,
high-demand, high-performance
workplace environments
that we can do
this in a way that
is beneficial, but doesn't take
a second more than is required.
All right.
So it's no surprise also
that mindfulness is getting
a lot of popular attention.
It's everywhere.
It's kind of surprising to me.
When I was starting this work,
it was actually ill-advised.
People thought nobody
would ever care
at all what I'm talking about
with mindfulness training.
And you want to study
the mindfulness in brain?
You're crazy.
But it's kind of
heartening to me that there
is a popular interest.
And as you know, one
of the reasons for this
is organizations like
this one, that see
the benefits for its employees.
And many other-- we
have sports figures,
military personnel,
members of Congress,
major corporations that embrace
mindfulness as something
that could be of value
for the people that are
part of those organizations.
And on par, like matching
the popular interest,
has been the research.
So what this is showing
you is the number
of research
publications from 1980
to last year, 2016 which
the term "mindfulness"
in the search.
And what you can see is obvious.
There's a meteoric rise, there's
this exponential increase
in the interest.
But if you can't see the
numbers very clearly,
last year there were 667 studies
published that had this term.
Impressive right?
Much better than 1980, where
there were 0 studies published.
But I'm mentioning this to you
because even though there's
a popular rise, there's
a scientific interest.
We're nowhere near
300,000 articles.
So everything I'm going to
share with you now with regard
to the state of this
research, I want
you to really hold a great--
take it with a grain of salt.
And I'm coming to you as
a mindfulness researcher.
I'm obviously very
committed to this topic.
But I think more important
to me than you understanding
the benefits of mindfulness or
the science that suggests that
it's beneficial is really
coming from a place--
my own intention as a scientist
to say, I want you to be--
as you go out into the world
and consume popular media
around mindfulness, I want you
to be responsible consumers
of the science that o see.
And the only way to be
responsible consumers
of the science is to actually
have an understanding of where
we're at and where we're not.
So that's going to
be the flavor of what
I want to share with you today,
but it is absolutely compelling
that we have this growing
rise in the science.
And I think it's
important to understand
what that means about what we
know now about mindfulness.
And as I go around to many
different organizations, most
recently-- last October,
it was at the Pentagon
I got asked this question.
You know, great.
You're here to talk
about mindfulness.
OK.
Cut to the chase.
Does it work?
And you know, it's like,
that's a big question.
But I actually think it's
absolutely a fair question
to ask.
Any leader wants to make sure
that what they have anybody
in their organization
do is worth the time
of these individuals.
But even though it's a
straightforward and important
question, I actually think
it's a bit of a complicated
question.
And I want to break down
what I mean by that.
So the first is
really this term "it."
Does "it" work?
Well, what the heck
do we mean by "it?"
"It" in our current day and
age is a world of options.
Imagine that, a
world of options.
You can think of acquiring
mindfulness, familiarity
with mindfulness or learning
about mindfulness training
through a book, a lecture, an
app, a retreat, a workshop.
There's so many
different things.
So when we want to determine
if something is effective,
if it works, we need to be
very specific about what
it is that we're evaluating.
And that's where, with
regard to the science,
one key aspect has been to
have manualized programs.
These are programs in which the
delivery of the program itself
is constrained in a
very specific way,
so that every time
it's delivered,
there are standards
that are upheld.
And that it's happening in the
same order and same sequence,
same duration, et cetera.
But I think it's
important to say upfront
that to know if something
works or not, you
need to be very precise
about what you're looking at.
And two of the most well-studied
and well-manualized programs
are Mindfulness-Based
Stress Reduction, MBSR,
developed by Jon Kabat-Zinn
at the UMass Medical School.
And another program related
to that, Mindfulness-Based
Cognitive Therapy,
which was developed
at the University of Toronto.
Both of these are about
eight-hour-- sorry,
eight weeks of training.
Eight consecutive weeks
where the participants
meet with the group, with a
qualified trainer for about two
to three hours a week.
And they're assigned daily
homework of about 45 minutes.
And we know exactly the
sequence of the program.
And we know what's done, right?
And this is a great way in
which we, as scientists,
can approach understanding
if it's effective.
Because now we at least know
what the container of "it"
is in this, does it work?
And now, there have
been enough studies
done investigating
this type of training
that we can aggregate the
results across multiple studies
and do what's called formally
meta-analyses, where we're
putting together
and statistically
testing how strong the effects
are across not just one or two
studies, but dozens of studies.
That gives us more
weight to the rigor
of what we're talking about.
But I think that with
regard to the weight
of what we're talking
about, well, what is it?
When you ask somebody, does
it work, well, what do you
mean by "work?"
What does it actually mean
for something to work?
And from my point
of view, it really
is in the spirit of asking
this very broad question, does
it reduce suffering?
Does it actually have a
beneficial impact on people?
And the field of research
around mindfulness
has actually thought
of it similarly.
Suffering, though,
is instantiated
in very specific sort
of silos of interest.
There are people interested
in understanding and exploring
ways in which we can reduce
suffering in the body.
Things like chronic
pain, or hypertension,
or psoriasis, or other
stress-related physiologic
ailments.
Or, suffering in the mind
with psychological disorders
from depression,
anxiety, PTSD, ADHD.
The names go on and on.
And the third kind
of area of research
has been the utility
of mindfulness training
with regard to suffering when
it comes to our relationships
with each other.
And I think this is where
workplace settings have a lot
to offer, because this
is when we can actually
see the impact of certain
members of a community learning
about and engaging
in these practices
and how it changes the
dynamics that exist.
So some of the
studies in this area,
which I would say is
really a newer area,
is looking at things like
marital relationships,
parent-child relationships.
And of course,
starting to be done
has been workplace settings.
So in asking about
whether something works,
we can go more deeply
into the particular areas.
And I'm listing some of these.
But of course, we
could go on and on
about all the different topics
that have been investigated.
Now we're at the point with
regard to these meta-analysis
where we can say, OK.
Across a variety of programs
that have been manualized
and are investigated
in a vigorous way,
what's the impact on
certain kinds of measures?
In this case, looking at
psychological and physical
measures.
So this was a study that
was a few years back now,
really in the premier journal
of the medical establishment
in this country, "The Journal of
American Medical Association."
And they had 47 studies
that they looked at,
3,500 participants.
And I want to make
a point here to say,
they did not conclude
that mindfulness
is some kind of magic answer
to all of life's woes.
Their conclusions were actually
that the effects are moderate--
10% to 20%.
This gives me a sense that this
is a realistic and solidly-done
study because probably it is
the case with the current state
of research with
such a few numbers
that that would make sense.
But I do want to point out what
they said that translates into,
because that I think
is quite compelling.
They said even though
it's moderate evidence
with 10% to 20% for these
things like depression and pain,
the effects are comparable
with what would be expected
from the use of
an anti-depressant
in a primary care population,
but without associated
toxicities.
And that, to me,
has the potential
to be some kind
of a game-changer.
If we can engage in
regular mental exercise
to have the effects comparable
to psychopharmacologic
solutions that are widely used,
that's pretty powerful stuff.
So I see this as a very
kind of promising beginning
of an endeavor.
And more studies have
gone on to do this where--
2 years ago, there was 115
randomized control trials.
And again, finding
similar benefits
with psychological illness
and physical functioning.
I want to make the point about
randomized controlled trials,
because that's sort of the
methodology of science.
That's the gold standard of
how we conduct our research.
We have people in a
randomized trial that
are enrolled into a
study without knowing
what condition, what
training program they're
going to be enrolled in.
And then they're
randomly assigned
to either get, let's say,
mindfulness-based stress
reduction, or nothing, or
some other program that's
matched along those dimensions.
And because they're
randomly assigned,
and because these programs
have been matched,
now if you find that one
group outperforms another,
you have more confidence that
it's because of the training
that they did.
So that's also very important.
When we look at studies
and their effectiveness,
are they holding the
highest standard of science
as they look at results?
So does it work?
Yes.
Right now, as I said
before, I'd love
to be able to consider
that this is where we're at
and happily go away now and
you're done for the afternoon.
But unfortunately,
that's not quite it.
And one of the things
that's coming up
is though the
evidence is quite--
is amassing at a very
fast pace, which is great,
there's actually been a lot
of upheaval in our field
as researchers in mindfulness.
One of the things that's
come up with regard to all
of these positive benefits
is that the field itself
may be biased in its reporting.
I love this one, "The power
of positive thinking skews
mindfulness studies."
I mean, I think it's
cute, but it's also
important to realize what the
costs of doing this might be.
And what does this
actually mean?
What does this mean that
there's a positive bias?
What it's saying is that
out of all the studies
that are done, out of all the
research studies that have been
funded from federal
agencies, like the NIH,
on mindfulness
training, far fewer
are reporting than should.
That's the first point.
There are fewer studies that
are actually being published
based on these funded projects.
And those that are reporting
are disproportionately positive.
So this raises a
lot of red flags
because it suggests
that there may
be a lot of studies that are
finding nothing, or finding
opposite or unexpected effects.
And people are
essentially leaving them
in their file drawers.
Right
And this, to me, is
sort of a call to action
for other scientists as well.
Publish those null results.
Publish studies in which
you find nothing or even
unexpectedly different things.
And why do I think
this is important?
Well, part of it
is because that's
the only way we're
going to understand
what best practices are.
If you do a mindfulness
training study
where your intervention is
five minutes over three days.
And you find that five minutes
of mindfulness practice
over three days has no
benefits, and you never
publish that, we'll never
know that that low of a dose
has no effect.
And it's important so
that we know at what level
we start seeing benefits.
Again, look at the
physical fitness analogy.
The number is not 3 steps a day.
It's 10,000 steps a day.
So where did that come from?
It came from knowing how
low you can go to still have
tractable benefits.
So that's my sort of
plea to other scientists
is that you have to
be more rigorous.
Publish null results.
A lot of efforts
now in the science
are to pre-register trials,
so that the moment you
get the funding, you actually
write the paper that says,
this is all what
I'm going to do.
And no matter what, no
matter what you find,
your study will be published.
So that if you
find nothing, it's
still going to get published.
And that helps put the load off
of the researcher, who that's
their main fear, is
like, if I find nothing,
nobody is going to publish this.
And I think that this
is a great direction
that science is going.
But from the point of
view of our conversation,
I just wanted to say, I'd
love to say the answer is yes,
but I won't say
the answer is yes.
Because it's actually not yes.
It's a highly provisional yes.
And if I could, I'd make the
font even smaller for the word
"yes."
Because I think so much
more research is needed.
We're nowhere near the numbers
regarding physical fitness.
And that's the only
way this is going
to be a sustainable
enterprise that's
beneficial for all of us.
All right.
But I wanted to
basically say this.
Does it work is important.
But as a neuroscientist, my
interest was not in that alone.
It was how.
How is it that the randomized
control trials that
have been done suggest that
mindfulness training is
beneficial for something like
psoriasis, having a better
marriage, and curing some
kind of psychological illness?
How is it even possible?
What is happening under the
hood, which is what drives us
and interests us in
looking at the brain.
So let's talk a little
bit about the brain
and what we know about the brain
with regard to mindfulness.
And I wanted to just
bring up this term that
is actually a pretty new term.
When I was in graduate school,
this notion of neuroplasticity
was not well-understood at all.
And a similar term,
actually a related term,
called neurogenesis--
the birth of new
neurons in the brain--
was not even probably coined
when I started my undergrad.
So what is neurogenesis?
What does that even mean?
Well, when I was
in graduate school,
the notion was that we were
born with a certain number
of neurons.
They developed into
early adulthood.
And then whatever we were
left with at that point
is the number of neurons we
had until the slow decline
and their death through
the course of our lives.
Not a very hopeful
scenario, right?
It's like, you have something
and then it'll just decline.
While I was in graduate
school-- actually,
toward the end of my time
in the mid-'90s, this term
"neurogenesis" in the
adult brain came about,
which was pretty exciting.
That means that adults
can grow new neurons.
And neuroplasticity, the brain
can actually reorganize itself
in a way that could actually
promote its better health.
We knew a lot about
neuroplasticity
from the stroke recovery side.
We know that people can get
better if they've been injured.
But this is suggesting,
even in a healthy brain,
you can get healthier through
the kinds of mental exercises
you engage in.
Why am I showing this
crumpled up piece of paper?
It's really just to kind
of demystify the brain.
The brain is essentially--
think of a sheet of tissue,
kind of sheets of tissue,
layered one on
top of each other.
So you got a stack of tissue
now crumpled up as tightly
as you possibly can, and then
put inside this handy container
called a skull.
And that's our brain.
And this crumpling up,
this tightly-packed nature
of those cell layers allows
for the efficient communication
between cells.
Now, it ends up that as
we age, as we have stress,
that crumpling diminishes.
The brains gets
smoother as we age.
And that suggests a
lack of efficiency
in our brain function.
So why am I'm mentioning this?
Because this is the
kind of thing people
are looking at with
regard to brain changes
that may be beneficial
with mindfulness training.
And I want to just
mention that, again,
when we look at the
brain, we're going
to look at it with
a very specific eye
to the kind of
cognitive training
we think that we're engaging in.
So this is, again, reminding you
of what that basic mindfulness
practice is, right?
Select, maintain, notice,
and control your mind wander.
And through the field of sort of
basic cognitive neuroscience--
nothing to do with the field
of contemplative neuroscience
or mindfulness, just basic
cognitive neuroscience,
we know a lot about how
the brain is activated
as a function of
selecting-- potentially
selecting and maintaining,
noticing, and mind wandering.
And that's shown in this slide.
This is a study done by,
actually, a researcher
at Stanford a few years back.
And what it's showing
you is that these
are identifiable brain networks
that exist in all of us
and that get activated
as a function of what
particular process, functional
process, we're engaged in.
So a couple of key things.
The particular regions
don't actually matter.
To me, it doesn't matter so
much that you know those.
But what it is important
to me that you know
is that these different
networks are basically,
for the most part,
non-overlapping.
Meaning that they're
taxing and activating
different parts of the brain.
And that they're
mutually inhibitory.
What do I mean by that?
Well, what that means is
if a brain network that
is involved in selecting and
maintaining is activated,
another network,
let's say having
to do with mind wandering,
is going to be deactivated.
And vice-versa.
If you are mind
wandering, the chances
of you being able to
fully activate the select
and maintain network
are reduced because
of this anti-correlation issue.
Now, I think that this is
important because not only does
it tell us about the nature
of how these processes work
in relationship to each
other, but they also
give us great
hypotheses of where
we think mindfulness
training may
have its structural
and functional effects.
Because these are
the processes that we
know from the
training program are
key to what's being exercised.
Does that make sense?
OK.
So what I wanted to
just tell you again,
sort of the state of
the field right now,
is that there have been
many functional studies.
There was a recent
meta-analysis of 78 studies.
What I'm showing you
here is a meta-analysis
of structural studies.
So this is just looking
at the brains of people
across multiple studies.
And the point I
want to make again,
the particular
regions aren't key.
But what's key is
that it's not random.
And that some of those
same nodes with regard
to selecting, maintaining,
and controlling mind wandering
are the ones that we are seeing
structural changes within,
suggesting-- and the nature
of those structural changes,
by the way, is this
improved gyrofication.
So it's like the
de-crumpling may
be happening as we kind of age
or as we experience stress.
But with practices like
daily mindfulness exercises,
there are certain nodes
that remain intact,
that don't show
that degradation.
And what's important
here, though.
I think this is very
interesting, that we see
tractable structural changes.
But there is
something I want to,
again, mention to you as being
honest brokers of the science.
These are not randomized
controlled trials.
These are studies done in people
that have chosen on their own
to practice mindfulness training
for, let's say, 5 to 20 years.
So when we see
changes like this,
it could be because
of the mindfulness,
but it could be that people that
decide to practice mindfulness
had other dietary choices,
different social networks,
different professional
choices that they make.
Or they may just be
different to begin with.
Their brains may--
even before they ever
started doing anything
having to do with meditation,
may have been different.
So what we don't
know from studies
like this is what's driving
the nature of the change, which
means that to actually be
rigorous in what we do,
we'd have to assign people to
different types of practices
and compare the structure
and function of their brain
after they engage in those
practices for a period of time.
But that's where the
science is headed.
That's what we want to do next.
Or we are doing, I should say.
OK.
So just to kind of
catch us up to speed,
you remember this figure
and the number of studies?
I want to just tell
you that we're now
at a very similar
point with regard
to the scientific
strategies we're
taking to examine mindfulness.
That we now know
what the brain looks
like when people are actively
engaging in practice.
Or what it looks like at rest
or the structural changes.
The growing area of research
from my point of view
that is still in need
of more bolstering
is looking at the impact.
Because I actually, frankly,
think this is the bottom line.
It's great that
your brain changes,
but if it has no impact
on your performance,
it's not worth a lot in
our day-to-day lives.
So one of the key questions
I've been interested in is,
how does engaging in a
formal mindfulness program,
for example, alter performance?
And our predictions there
are straightforward as well.
We would expect
and, in fact, this
is showing you a
subset of studies
that are showing
that people that
engage in a multi-week
mindfulness training
program compared to
those who don't or do
some other kind of
program, improve
their performance on
selective attention tasks,
working memory tasks, and
they reduce the amount of mind
wandering that
they're reporting.
And I think this
is very exciting
because it suggests that
you can functionally
improve people in
their performance
as a function of this training.
And I just wanted to now end
by saying that in the work
that we're doing, as
I said at the outset,
our interest isn't so much--
we want people to get
better, of course.
But we want to see if we
can use mindfulness training
in a strategic way
to build resilience
in groups that are really
vulnerable to having
degradation in these processes.
And one of the programs
that we've developed called
Mindfulness-Based
Attention Training,
as you can see the
military look--
MBAT.
It's intended for soldiers and
for military family members.
It allows us to see if
it's the case that offering
people mindfulness
training before they begin
that intensive period of
pre-deployment training
or even deploying,
to see if we can
protect against the
declines that might come.
All right.
I think I'm going to
have to wrap up now,
but I wanted to just
end on this note.
And basically, share
with you that where
are we in the
state of the field?
Where we're at in the
state of the field
is this understanding that
we have now identified
a problem space with
regard to the science
that we can actually pursue.
We can pursue in a
systematic and rigorous way
to answer more questions.
And we are finding
that there are benefits
to physical well-being,
to psychological health,
to relationships, and stress
protective effects to things
like degradation and
attention, and working memory,
and mind wandering.
But I also want to say that
there's a lot more science
to be done.
And we're nowhere
near the threshold
we need to reach to produce
a cultural understanding
that the mind,
just like the body,
needs to be exercised
daily for optimum wellness.
And I hope that through
our continued efforts,
we'll be able to do so.
So I'll just end by thanking
all of you for your attention.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MARIO GALARRETA:
Thank you so much.
It was a fantastic talk.
AMISHI JHA: Thank you.
MARIO GALARRETA: We are going
to have time for a couple--
three questions.
So if anybody in the
room has a question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You mentioned that public
knowledge and interest
in mindfulness training
and mindfulness in general
has become exponentially
more popular in recent years.
I was wondering how the
pop culture understanding
of mindfulness affects
the perception of the work
that you do?
AMISHI JHA: Well, it
leads me to giving talks
like the one I
just gave, which is
that I think that the
public interest is outpacing
what the science can deliver.
And I think that
part of it means
that as scientists who are
actively doing this work,
we have to say where
we're really at.
Because it's not a cure-all.
Its effects aren't
lasting if you just
read a book on mindfulness.
And that type of
notion can actually
be problematic for people.
And probably, would
result in them disengaging
from practicing altogether
because they have
an unrealistic view
of what it takes
to actually see benefits and
change in their own life.
So that's where I'm at.
I'm at trying to course
correct a little bit
and have the hype
kind of dwindle
and the rigor of
the science increase
to get it to a better place.
MARIO GALARRETA: OK.
More questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks
for your talk.
I had a question about
the emotional side.
So have there been
research published
on the effect of the emotions
while either being mindful
or in the moment of stress,
like how has that been handled?
Whether it's a flight or fight
or fear, anger, or anything
like that.
AMISHI JHA: Yeah, absolutely.
So I think that that
is a very important--
and it may seem
unrelated to attention,
but it's actually
deeply intertwined
with the attentional
work that I was sharing.
Because it ends up
that these aspects
of our emotional response to an
experience tend to be the thing
that can hijack our attention
away from the moment.
So if you're having
a fear response
or you're having
anger, that content
consumes the
attentional resources
available in the moment.
So part of what we're seeing
actually in some of our work
is that when we increase
the capacity of working
memory and attention,
we can actually
improve emotion regulation.
So for example, in
pre-deployment Marines,
what we found is that
if we do nothing at all,
their negative mood--
as you can imagine,
their negative mood
increased in the
eight-week period
as they approached
pre-deployment.
Got more negative.
And stress, the same way.
Anxiety, the same way.
Everything gets more profound.
But when we offered
mindfulness training,
those that actually practiced
did not get that increase,
but only if they actually showed
improvements in their working
memory.
So what we think is happening
is that that ability to hold
and grow this
mental white space,
this internal
capacity to control
the contents of your
present moment experience,
can give you a better
ability to handle
and deal with those
negative emotions.
Does that answer your question?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Just a quick question.
So you mentioned there
is different trainings
in different studies.
From a practical
perspective, what
is the threshold you are looking
right now when, I guess--
AMISHI JHA: Great question.
AUDIENCE: --meditation
actually seems to matter?
AMISHI JHA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What's
the minimum number?
AMISHI JHA: Thank you.
So the question was
regarding threshold, right?
So it's kind of one of those
cut to the chase things.
Do I have to go on a three-month
intensive silent retreat
to have any benefit or can
I do five minutes a day?
Is that kind of what you
mean, like where are we at?
So that's actually
what I've been spending
the last five or so years in
my lab doing across four DOD
grants.
Because they want to
know the same thing.
It's like, how much
is enough, but not
more than we need to
actually produce benefits?
Now, enough, what
we need, I mean,
all those are fluid, right?
I mean, nobody's
promising that you're
going to have fully enlightened,
never disregulate person
going through these programs.
You're going to have people
that have better attention
and better mood, for example.
And what we've done
is we started out
with using this 8-week model
of MBSR, which is around 8
weeks and 40 hours or more.
And what we did in our studies
with active-duty military is
we said, we're going to
still hold this 8 week
period of time, but we're
going to actually cut the time
to 24 hours in 1 program.
So that would be 3 hours a week.
In another group, we'd
do 2 hours a week.
So 16.
In another group, we did
1 hour a week, 8 hours.
And what we looked to see
is what the differences
were in their mood,
in their attention,
in their working
memory, et cetera.
And what we found is that we
could go as low as 8 hours
and still see benefits, but
only if those 8 hours actually
included an emphasis
on practice.
So we had a comparison
8-hour program
where the same trainer
talked about mindfulness,
but only really talked
about mindfulness,
wasn't spending as much time in
class practicing mindfulness.
That was the equivalent
of doing nothing at all.
So as you shorten the
duration of the training,
the proportion of time spent
actually practicing in class
is key.
So now through my work
with Scott Rogers,
we've gone on to see if 4
weeks or 2 weeks with 8 hours
is beneficial.
And what we're finding
is that we can now
see in 4 weeks and 8
hours, the benefit.
But that's more than half
the class being practice.
So that's the nature
of how it's looking.
MARIO GALARRETA: OK.
So our time is up.
And I just want
to say, thank you
so much for doing this work.
And thank you for coming
here to share it with us.
AMISHI JHA: It's
my great pleasure.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]